this car TV ocher she is gearing up to
reunite with JLo in the upcoming
stripper movie hustlers something cardi
knows I haven't been on set yet but I
worked with her before
BG she's just so caring I could say do
you need this do you need that like what
do you need do you want this a former
stripper in real life cardi says she
can't wait to shoot her scenes I had to
be in this movie
all the actress in the in the movie I
could tell them like no no no this is
how it goes that's the type of clubs
that I work she really wanted me to do
like this I think like the second lead
role and due to the fact that I gotta
work on my album I got like a little
smaller role yeah this 26 year old mama
to 9 month old culture has a lot going
on a Vegas residency at the Palms new
music with husband offset and on May 8th
her second line for fashion Nova drops
her first sold out in minutes with doing
high fashion on an affordable budget we
started off with like 200 pieces and I
used to be like scotch scotch great with
to wear this which I love how involved
you are you're like lady boss cardi be
amazing yeah say here goes oh one one in
my nose are you sure these don't bite
we talked about your abs by the way
getting that Instagram post yeah girl
what are you doing stop stop
you look amazing I just got my boobs
redone did you really yes
when is the beauty line coming soon very
you get oh you're gettin a toe
[Music]
[Applause]